gleiches recht für alle das internet
eröffnet vielen menschen mit behinderung
neue kommunikationswege eine deutsche
online aktivisten zeigt wie man mit
blogs politik machen kann
julia probst beim kirchentag in hamburg
die gehörlose bloggerin ist sauer
sie will eine diskussionsrunde mit
joachim gauck verfolgen
doch von ihrem sitzplatz aus kann sie
den bundespräsidenten nicht sehen
dabei wird ausgerechnet hier über die
rechte von menschen mit behinderungen
gesprochen
die 31-jährige diskutiert so lange bis
eine neue stuhlreihe aufgebaut wird
für die gehörlosen ein kleiner sieg aber
für julia probst nur eine etappe
die bloggerin hat einen auftrag für das
online magazin des wohlfahrtsverbands
diakonie prüft sie die barrierefreiheit
der großveranstaltung außerdem
verschickt sie ihre beobachtungen an
rund 24.000 twitter-follower manchmal im
fünf minuten takt
in ihrem blog meinen augenschmaus führt
sie besonders wichtige themen weiter aus
das web hat das leben der gehörlosen
stark verändert ihr ehrenamtliches
engagement hat ihr eine nominierung bei
the bobs eingebracht mit dem preis
zeichnet die deutsche welle seit 2004
internationale online aktivisten aus
gewonnen hat in diesem jahr der
chinesische menschenrechtler liu xiaobo
julia probst hat das zweitbeste
abstimmungsergebnis bekommen
der deutsche journalist falk steiner
konnte viele jury kollegen von ihrem
blog überzeugen
in deutschland ist das inzwischen zwar
relativ weit aber noch lange nicht beim
optimum angekommen in vielen anderen
ländern ist es so dass man klar sagen
muss
dort werden behinderte letzten endes
weggeschlossen sehr sehr stark
benachteiligt und sie ganz am ende von
dem was man gesellschaft nennt und
deswegen war es mir auch sehr wichtig
dass in diese internationale jury auch
mit einzubringen
jürgen allein reicht julia probst aber
nicht mehr seit sieben monaten ist sie
kandidatin der piratenpartei für die
bundestagswahl
dort will sie für die gleichstellung von
menschen mit behinderung kämpfen denn
sie hat selbst erfahren wie intolerant
ihre umwelt sein kann
nach einem fernseh interview hält sie
zahllose hass kommentare viele absender
machen sich über ihre stimme lustig die
bürgerin zieht sich zurück überdenkt
ihre kandidatur aber schliesslich macht
sie weiter die bundestagswahlen sind am
22 september dann entscheidet sich ob
deutschland bereit ist für die erste
gehörlose abgeordnete shift meint eine
frau mit viel power